DeDes images de Trois-Rivières
ouoù le candidat à la chefferie
dudu Parti conservateur, Pierre
PoPoilievre, avec son épouse, et
vevenu s'adresser à des militan.
IlIl est avec nous, pendant qu'n
vovoit l'ancien maire de Trois-
RiRivières, M. Lévesque, qui est
unun de vos... un de ceux qui vs
apappuient. M. Poilievre, bonso.
- - Bonsoir.
- - Vous êtes deux, trois jours
auau Québec. Comment ça votre
cacampagne au Québec?
PaParce qu'on a dit que M. Chart
avavait beaucoup beaucoup d'app.
EsEst-ce que vous commencez à
sesentir que vous avez des appus
auaussi?
- - On a eu des grands
rarassemblements ici à Montréal
hihier, à Trois-Rivières, à
QuQuébec. On avait 250 personnes
trtrès enthousiastes. Alors mon
memessage de liberté et chèque
dede paie fonctionne très bien
auau Québec. Les gens veulent
rereprendre le contrôle de
leleur vie avec... en rendant
lele Canada le plus libre
auau monde. En même temps,
ilils veulent un candidat qui
pepeut contrer l'inflation
ququ'a causée le gouvernement
popour protéger la valeur de
leleur chèque de paie et
leleur pouvoir d'achat.
- - On va parler de tout ça.
M.M. Poilievre, première questin
: : si vous aviez été premier
miministre, est-ce que les camis
seseraient encore devant
lele Parlement à Ottawa?
- - Non, en fait, les camions
n'n'auraient jamais été devant
lele Parlement.
- - Pourquoi?
- - La raison pour laquelle
ilils étaient là, c'était
paparce que Justin Trudeau
a a créé une obligation vaccinae
popour eux, deux ans après,
- - On a eu des grands
rarassemblements ici à Montréal
hihier, à Trois-Rivières, à
QuQuébec. On avait 250 personnes
DoDonc, il n'y aurait jamais eu
unune manifestation.
- - Non. C'est allé trop loin.
- - Mais encore une fois,
sisi la santé publique dit à
mamais voyons au Québec, en
OnOntario, à Ottawa, "Vous devrz
exexiger telle chose", est-ce qe
vovous seriez d'accord? Ou vous
didiriez
"N"Non, je vous écoute pas"?
- - Non, j'écouterais la scienc.
MaMais c'est... le problème,
EsEst-ce que vous écouteriez
lala santé publique vous dit :
onon doit faire telle ou telle
c'c'est nécessaire ni efficace."
AlAlors, il n'y a pas de science
enen arrière de ça. C'était juse
unune attaque contre la classe
ououvrière, une attaque entre
leles gens qui ont livré nos
prproduits et nos services.
EtEt c'est la raison pour laquee
j'j'ai appuyé leurs efforts
dede protéger leur liberté et
leleur chèque de paie.
- - Et ça vous inquiète pas
dedevoir, Pierre Poilievre, que
c'c'était financé par certains
grgroupes d'extrêmes droites aux
EÉtats-Unis, que les gens n'ont
ababsolument pas respecté la loi
etet l'ordre que vous prônez
popourtant?
- - Mais j'ai dit... même avant
l'l'arrivée à Ottawa de ces
cacamionneurs, on m'a demandé :
esest-ce que j'allais appuyer
cecela? J'ai dit que j'allais
apappuyer la cause des gens qui
veveulent protéger leur chèque
dede paie et leur liberté et
ququi se se comportent bien,
totout en condamnant des indivis
ququi se comportent mal ou
ququi brisent la loi ou qui font
dedes blocages de l'infrastructe
esessentielle. Et c'est exactemt
cece que j'ai répété durant toue
lala période. C'est exactement
cece que j'ai dit pendant toute
leles manifestations qu'on a vu.
- - Mais disons que vous n'êtes
papas un grand fan des mesures
sasanitaires?
- - Non.
- - Disons ça comme ça.
- - Non. C'est allé trop loin.
- - Mais encore une fois,
sisi la santé publique dit à
mamais voyons au Québec, en
OnOntario, à Ottawa, "Vous devrz
exexiger telle chose", est-ce qe
vovous seriez d'accord? Ou vous
didiriez
"N"Non, je vous écoute pas"?
- - Non, j'écouterais la scienc.
MaMais c'est... le problème,
c'c'est que Justin Trudeau
n'n'écoute pas la science
mamaintenant. Il est en train de
gagarder en place ses obligatio,
mmême quand le reste du monde
esest en train de les enlever.
IlIl n'y a aucune raison pour
lalaquelle on devrait garder
enen place ces mesures qui
atattaquent les libertés des ge,
ququi causent la dépression
paparmi les jeunes qui sont isos
dede leurs activités physiques
etet leurs amis. Beaucoup de...
- - Mais encore une fois,
M.M. Poilievre, la santé publiqe
ne dit pas ce que vous dites.
- - Non, non, non. Ce n'est pas
vrvrai. Maintenant, on est allés
bebeaucoup plus loin que ce que
lala science nous demande et
c'c'est la raison pour laquelle
onon voit les provinces qui sont
enen train d'enlever ces mesures
sasanitaires. Mais Justin Trudeu
veveut continuer, parce qu'il ae
lele pouvoir. Il aime le pouvoir
quque la pandémie lui a donné.
EnEn fait, ce n'est pas moi qui
didit ça, c'est Joël Lightbound,
soson propre député libéral,
ququi a dit que Justin Trudeau
l'l'utilise pour diviser les ges
etet prendre le pouvoir. Je suis
d'd'accord avec le libéral
JoJoël Lightbound là-dessus.
- - Mais au gros de la cinquième
cocourbe, est-ce que vous auriez
étété d'accord pour dire aux
gegens : "Vous allez vous priver
dede liberté?"
C'C'est ça la question.
- - Vous parlez d'auparavant?
AuAu début?
- - En novembre dernier,
enen décembre dernier, janvier
dedernier, quand ça s'est t mis
àà remonter.
- - Au début, il y avait
unune raison pour avoir
dedes mesures sanitaires,
c'c'est sûr. Mais après du temp,
c'c'était clair que ce n'est pas
lala science qui a guidé
leles politiciens, surtout au
niniveau fédéral : c'était
lele pouvoir. Et Mme Freeland,
unune autre libérale, a dit que
lala COVID était une opportunité
popolitique. Et c'est comme ça
quque les libéraux l'ont vu.
C'C'est exactement ce que
M.M. Lightbound a dit quand
ilil a accusé son propre premier
miministre de son propre parti
d'd'utiliser le COVID comme
unun outil politique pour
didiviser les Canadiens.
JeJe suis contre ça. Je suis
popour la liberté des gens.
- - Vous êtes un batailleur,
onon le voit.
- - Exactement.
- - En politique, depuis le déb,
onon vous suit. On a l'impressin
paparfois que vous vous présentz
cocomme le seul conservateur
dede tous ces gens-là, de tous
leles candidats. "M. Charest
esest libéral"l", vous dites.
M.M. Brown, vous dites :
"A"Ah! On peut pas l'écouter.
IlIl y a haussé les taxes
égégalement, taxe carbone, etc."
EÊtes-vous le seul vrai
coconservateur?
- - Non, je ne dirais pas ça.
J'J'ai beaucoup de respect
popour Mme Leslyn Lewis qui est
unune vraie conservatrice,
trtrès, très qualifiée, qui est
unune bonne, très, très bonne
pepersonne. Mais oui, je suis
unun batailleur et les Canadiens
onont besoin d'un batailleur.
LeLe jeune homme de 32 ans qui
vivit dans le sous-sol de
sasa mère parce que les prix
dede l'immobilier ont doublé
enen cinq ans, il a besoin
d'd'un batailleur pour lui.
LeLes personnes âgées qui paient
trtrop pour la nourriture, qui
pepeuvent pas... qui sont parmi
leles quatre sur cinq familles
ququi ont dû réduire leur régime
alalimentaire à cause des coûts
dede leur nourriture,
ilils ont besoin d'un batailleu.
LeLe travailleur qui ne peut pas
papayer les factures de l'essen,
ilil a besoin d'un batailleur.
EtEt c'est moi qui va contrer
l'l'inflation que Justin Trudeau
a a causé et ça prend batailleur
popour le faire.
- - Et M. Charest est un libéra,
vovous dites. Ce n'est pas
unun conservateur.
- - Il est un libéral. C'est pas
jujuste e la marque de commerce,
c'c'est politique. Il a augmenté
lala taxe de vente ici au Québec
dedeux fois. Il a ajouté une ta,
unune autre taxe sur l'essence t
unune taxe carbone. Il veut cibr
leles chasseurs et les fermiers
auau lieu des vrais criminels.
CeCe sont des politiques du
PaParti libéral. Moi, je suis
coconservateur. Je veux réduire
dedes taxes, rendre la vie
plplus abordable et contrer
l'l'inflation.
- - L'inflation. Qu'est-ce que
vovous faites avec les taxes
susur l'essence? On les enlève,
onon les... on les baisse,
ouou quoi?
- - On va éliminer pour...
MaMais, premièrement, je vais
éléliminer la taxe carbone pour
réréduire le prix de l'essence
etet ça va réduire aussi le coût
dede nourriture et de chauffage,
paparce que la taxe augmente
lele prix de tout. Deuxièmement,
jeje mettrais fin à cette pratie
d'd'imprimer de l'argent pour
fifinancer les déficits
exexorbitants. Quand on ajoute
auaux monnaies sans ajouter
auaux productions des biens et
seservices, ça augmente toujours
lele coût. Plus de dollars qui
acachètent moins de services,
auaugmente le coût. Donc,
jeje vais arrêter l'impression
dede l'a'argent pour protéger
lala valeur de notre monnaie et
rerendre les chèques de paie
plplus puissants.
- - Où vous coupez? Parce que
vovous voulez arriver plus viteà
unun déficit zéro. Vous couperù?
PaPar exemple, le 6 milliards qe
lele gouvernement fédéral envoie
auau Québec pour les garderies.
VoVous coupez ça?
- - On verra combien ça fonctioe
paparce que, maintenant, on a vu
auaucun résultat. Les libéraux
onont dépensé, ils ont promis
dedes garderies abordables
dedepuis 30 ans, mais encore
dedepuis six ans au pouvoir et
onon n'a vu de résultats. Alors,
sisi ça marche et si ça réduit
dedes coûts de garderie, moi,
jeje suis pour ça. Mais, si on
dédépense juste pour la...
- - Donc, vous garderiez...
vovous garderiez le deal avec
OtOttawa et Québec?
- - Mais si... on n'obtient pas
leles résultats, comme auparava,
leles libéraux ont dépensé
dedes milliards et des milliards
enen disant que ça allait réduie
leles taux... des frais des
gagarderies, mais on a rien vu
enen termes de résultat,
apaprès toutes ces dépenses-là.
LeLes garderies sont plus chères
quque jamais. Et moi, je vais
memettre l'argent directement
dadans les poches de monsieur
etet madame Tout-le-Monde,
dedes parents.
- - Je comprends.
MaMais l'entente de 6 milliards,
vovous la maintenez ou pas?
- - On verra si ça fonctionne,
sisi ça livre des résultats!
MaMaintenant, on a vu que
leles libéraux ont fait beaucoup
dede promesses par rapport
auaux coûts des garderies,
mamais ils ont dépensé sur
lala bureaucratie sans aucun
rérésultat pour les parents.
MoMoi, j'aimerais mettre l'arget
dadans la poche des parents et
nonon pas les politiciens.
- - Pipeline : M. Charest
enen parle aussi. Vous en parle.
EsEst-ce que vous pourriez
ututiliser le pouvoir fédéral
ququi existe d'imposer un pipele
vevers l'est, donc sur l'Ontari,
susur le Québec?
- - Mais, il n'y a pas une telle
prproposition maintenant.
MaMais, je vais vous dire
trtrès ouvertement, j'étais
popour Énergie-Est et on serait
dadans une meilleure position
auaujourd'hui en Europe avec
lala Russie si on avait Énergie-
EsEst, qui aurait transporté
1 1 million de barils de l'Ouest
cacanadien vers l'Est canadien
popour l'exporter aux pays
dédémocratiques. Maintenant,
àà cause du fait qu'on a tué
cece projet, on voit que l'Euroe
dédépend sur Poutine et
susur d'autres dictateurs.
L Le choix n'est pas pétrole
ouou pas de pétrole. Le Bloc
etet les libéraux sont
popour le pétrole étranger.
MoMoi, je suis pour l'énergie
cacanadienne, et les Québécois
sosont d'accord avec moi.
LeLes sondages, à plusieurs
rereprises, ont montré que
leles Québécois, si on doit
ututiliser...
- - OK, s'il y a un projet,
MoMonsieur Poilièvre?
- - S'il y a un projet, il faut
chchoisir entre le pétrole
ététranger, le pétrole canadien.
JeJe choisirais les travailleurs
cacanadiens à chaque fois.
- - S'il y a un projet énergie ,
esest-ce que vous imposez
lele pipeline.
- - Mais, je pense que
leles Québécois appuieront
totous les projets pour aider
l'l'indépendance énergétique
dudu Canada, et je travaillerai
enen collaboration avec eux
popour favoriser la production e
nonotre énergie et nos ressourc.
EtEt parlant d'imposer,
ququi a demandé aux Québécois
lala permission d'avoir ces
imimportations de pétrole
ététranger? Personne ne leur
a a demandé ça. Justin Trudeau
l'l'impose sans le consentement
dedes Québécois.
- - Mais s'il y a un projet et
ququ'une province s'y oppose,
vovous avez le droroit? Non, mas
c'c'est parce que le fédéral,
vovous avez ce droit-là.
IlIl faut clair avant, pendant
etet après. Est-ce que vous
popourriez l'imposer?
- - Vous me demandez
dede me prononcer sur un projet
ququi n'existe actuellement pas.
EÉvidemment, je dois avoir
unun projet avant de dire,
dede prononcer sur le projet.
MaMais je vais dire le principe,
c'c'est que je pense que les
ololéoducs, les gazoducs sont ls
memeilleures façons de transporr
l'l'énergie. C'est le plus
sésécuritaire, et l'énergie
cacanadienne est beaucoup mieux
quque d'importer l'énergie
ététrangère, et les Québécois
sosont d'accord.
- - Maxime Bernier a-t-il
unune place dans votre parti?
- - Non. Il a choisi de quitter
lele parti. Il veut pas être
unun conservateur.
- - Vous voulez abolir CBC,
dodonc Radio-Canada. Pourquoi?
PoPourquoi pas avoir une télé
pupublique au Canada?
- - Je vois la différence entre
CBCBC anglais et Ici RDI, et je
vavais vous expliquer pourquoi.
MoMoi, ma philosophie,
lele principe, c'est que le
gogouvernement devrait faire que
leles choses que le marché et
leles gens ne peuvent pas faire
papar eux-mêmes. Ce que CBC
ananglais fait, c'est déjà fait.
C'C'est disponible. À peu près
totoutes les informations
ququ'on reçoit de CBC en anglais
sosont déjà disponibles par
d'd'autres médias. Même leur
cocouverture de Washington,
ilils ne font que répéter CNN,
c'c'est même... Souvent, ils
mementionnent même pas l'existee
dudu Canada, même si on dit que
c'c'est pour protéger l'identité
cacanadienne...
- - Alors que Radio-Canada,
popour les francophones?
- - Je reconnais que le marché e
fofournit pas tous les nouvelles
etet tout cette culture et
ininformations en français parce
quque nous vivons évidemment
dadans un océan de l'anglais
enen Amérique du Nord. Alors,
c'c'est facile pour le m marché
dede livrer ça. Il n'y a pas
auautant de médias.
- - OK. Donc, concrètement,
enen 10 secondes?
- - Mes propositions là-dessus
seseront claires, mais je veux
jujuste vous dire que le princi,
c'c'est que oui, je comprends
ququ'il y a un besoin dans la
lalangue française qui n'existe
papas dans la langue anglaise
enen termes de médias.
- - Pierre Poilièvre, on va suie
cecette course, qui risque d'ête
fafascinante, au leadership
coconservateur. Merci.
- - Merci de m'avoir invité.
J'J'apprécie